a report card tonight on one of
President Trump's signature moves
correspondent Doug McElroy reports on
the president's sole appointment so far
to the highest court in the land today
marks the first year on the bench for
Supreme Court justice Neil Gorsuch there
have been no unpleasant surprises for
those who supported him Gorsuch always
has impressed people as being brilliant
jurists and we're looking forward to the
first opinions that he's writing which
will really show his thinking on key
issues and consternation among those
opposed to it it's interesting to see
exactly how he has voted in line with
the most extreme conservative justice on
the court in roughly 60 votes thus far
Gorsuch has been closely aligned with
Justice Clarence Thomas voting with him
in 14 of 17 non-unanimous rulings three
big decisions await on gerrymandering
the Trump travel ban and a religious
liberty case masterpiece cake shop
versus the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission in December arguments corset
seemed troubled that Colorado civil
rights law should force a Christian
Baker to violate his religious beliefs
in baking a wedding cake for a gay
couple and training his staff in such
accommodation because presumably he has
to tell his staff including his family
members that his Christian beliefs are
discriminatory corsets has proven
himself an active thoughtful questioner
though not as much now as when he first
took the bench observers say nor is he
as aggressive as his predecessor Antonin
Scalia but he bears an important
similarity to Scalia a belief in less is
more he reflects the Trump
administration's priority for judicial
picks a preference for less activism
more interpretation of existing law
that's no comfort for progressives who
note the stable of potential Trump Court
picks considering that when Donald Trump
was choosing who his justice would be he
had a list of 21 nominees and Gorsuch
was supposed to be the most moderate but
it's music to the ears of conservatives
if you follow appellate law and you look
at the names that they're putting up
there it's an all-star cast for such
appears to carry himself like the
Colorado when he is asked recently what
he would be if not a lawyer he said a
ski instructor and a fly fishing guide
right Doug thank you